here's what we're going to do okay this
tax payable right I'm going to change
this with a different kind of formula
I'm going to use this if thing this
thing right and you can see how this one
right it can tell which income bracket I
should be in and therefore what tax i
should get so let's do a simple one
first okay i'm going to set equals and
say give okay are we going to get along
so yeah so delete all this stuff down
here you're back to your three thousand
dollars but i don't know what the income
should be all right now i should say if
and if i come back to my tax table come
back to my tax tale i should actually
start back up here cuz what if i don't
work that much what if i go back down
under here then I want my spreadsheet to
be able to say yeah you don't get any
tax okay so here's what I'm going to say
if my gross income right is less than
eighteen thousand two hundred weight
okay look at that I'll write it up for
you just so that when i press anti it
doesn't disappear so i'm saying if be 10
which is my gross income right if it's
less than eighteen thousand two hundred
okay then how much tax should i have if
i'm less than eighteen thousand two
hundred its own no tax right so i should
say zero or if you like you could say in
in quite much you could say no tax
thanks very modest fine all right now
what should happen if it's false right
well then you should start applying some
tax shouldn't you okay you should apply
nineteen cents for every dollar over
18,000 200 right so I'll save you a bit
of work this is what we're going to have
this
minus anything wrong ok I'll leave that
up there so Makka the leader so have a
look this is I'll put some space in such
easier to read this is the condition
we're meeting right so if you're less
than eighteen thousand two hundred cool
no touch but if it's over 18,000 300
then you're going to get this amount at
why is thanking about okay yes the
reason why there to bracket is because
I'm going nineteen percent nineteen
percent times and then I start new
bracket two colors them for you to make
it easier what is be 10 minus eighteen
thousand two hundred it's each dollar
over 18,000 200 is it gonna be like a
thousand well i'll hit enter are you
ready for me together today okay hi I'm
gonna keep going I'll come to you in a
minute now let's suppose I work less
let's come back up here let's say you
worked only 20 weeks what do you expect
to happen you'll have less income and
you'll have so much less income that how
much tax you expect to pay let's Tesla
no time there you go it worked the
question is as you go up tax brackets
and burn more and more and more okay
what happens to all that previous amount
of money um here's the way it works give
this tax packet you pay nothing that's
great okay in this tax bracket up here
the next one your first eighteen
thousand two hundred dollars don't get
taxed okay it's only the dollars or over
eighteen thousand two hundred they're
the ones that get taxed okay but then
what happens when you go out to here
just think about this with me suppose
you earned exactly thirty seven thousand
dollars in fact we don't have to say if
let's go into here and say let's change
this gross income through thirty seven
thousand dollars right spreadsheet or do
this for us right you get it
so what does that mean that's how much
potential pain thirty-seven thousand
dollars you earn that's how much they
take out right so then when you cross
over the threshold for the next like if
I earn believe that seven thousand
dollars and one right all the following
dollars will get taxed at a higher rate
look 3572 dollars that's how much that's
how much tax you paid on your first
thirty seven thousand volts okay after
that you pay a higher rate right see it
goes nineteen cents per dollar thirty
two and a half cents per dollar the
seven cents per dollar and so on okay
I've do a bit of three dozen yeah that's
right okay so this is your tax for all
of these levels above and then you start
paying a higher rate for your dollar
jobs in that war that's thought okay so
so here I am in this frakkin right serve
right out the gate for the first $80,000
of my income I'm paying that much tax
okay and then all the amount that I'm
earning over this i'm paying vitamin
okay all right now here's our
spreadsheet this spreadsheet is cool
because it takes into account two
different tax brackets namely below
eighteen thousand three hundred and a
bulb but it doesn't take into account
the next one or the next one after that
or the next one after that how would we
work out these tax brackets down here